اخر ما كان صدر رسميا في اسرائيل بهذا
الخصوص هو تصريح نسب الى رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو قال فيه بان الاتصالات مستمره مع
الوسيطين القطري والمصري بهذا الخصوص لكن
مصادره قالت انها لم تحقق اي تقدم وليس
هناك اي اختراق نتنياهو جاء تصريحه قبل ان
ياتي هذا الخبر الذي نقلته القناه الثانيه
ع في محاوله
لارضاء وتهدئه من خاطر اهالي الاسرى
الاسرائيليين في قطاع غزه والتاكيد لهم
بان حكومته تواصلوا عملها على نطاق واسع
وبجهود كبيره من اجل استعادتهم لكن
العمليه العسكريه ستظل مستمره بكل قوتها
كعامل ضغط من اجل تسريع عمليه استعادتهم
وفق ما قاله ووفق ما كان قد عاد عليه
مسؤولون اخرون بينهم هيرتس هليفي رئيس
هيئه ركان وكذلك الناطق العسكري خلال
الايام الاخيره هذه التصريحات تاتي بوتيره
متفاوته وكثيره وكثيره الانباء التي تتحدث
عن ان هناك صفقه وهناك اقتراح تم تقديمه
لكن حتى الساعه ليس هناك ما يشير الى وجود
اي اختراق او تقدم بهذا الخصوص ومن غير
الواضح الى اي مدى ستسهم زياره وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه بلينكن بهذا شان لكن
نتنياهو كان في اليومين الماضيين ايضا قد
اقدم على خطوه اثارت ضده غضبا تتعلق بمنع
رئيسي الشباك والموساد من المشاركه في
اجتماع امني مع وزير الدفاع ومع رئيس هيئه
الاركان وعاد ليبرر بان رئيس المساد الذي
يتولى هذه المفاوضات هو قادر ومفوض
بمواصلة امنيه عمليات ضروريه حسب ما رشح
من معلومات بهذا الخصوص كل هذه التصريحات
في اسرائيل تاتي بهدف اولا محاوله اظهار
ان هناك اهتمام وان القضيه ما زالت تتصدر
جدول الاعمال لان لدى الذوي المحتجزين في
قطاع غزه مشاعر وشكوك ان رئيس الحكومه
نتنياهو غير مكترث وان القضيه لا
تتصدر اولويات اهتمام القياده السياسيه
والعسكريه الاسرائيليه وانه يريد المضي في
هذه الحرب حتى لو كانت ستعرض حياه ابنائهم
الى الخطر هؤلاء في مظاهراتهم المتواصله
وكان اخرها مظاهره وانطلقت من تلبيب قبل
نحو خمسه ايام ووصلت امس الاول كانوا
يرفعون شعارات تطالب بتنحيه نتنياهو
وتحميله المسؤوليه وتطالب بوقف تام لاطلاق
النار وبالتالي حتى لو كان المقابل هو هو
ابرام صفقه تبادل للاسرى كامله بمعنى ان
يتم اخلاء سبيل كل المحتجزين الاسرائيليين
والاسرى في قطاع غزه في مقابل الاسرى
الفلسطينيين لكن واضح ان حسب المعلومات
الاكيده المتوفره ان التباين بين موقفي
حماس واسرائيل كبير جدا حماس تطالب بوقف
تام لاطلاق النار قبل الخوض في هذه
المساله واسرائيل كانت في قبل نحو اسبوعين
تحدثت عن مقترح ب كبادرة